there is a Minnesota Schoolboard
candidate who is insistent on giving
kids little kids a way to identify
allies to talk about sex without telling
their parents when my wife and I were
looking at schools and everything where
we wanted to move we wanted a place that
was affordable and we wanted a place
where we knew they could grow up to be
whoever they grew up to be whoever they
loved and that's why we're in Minnesota
because we knew that whoever our boys
would grow up to be they were growing up
in a safe space and we need to make sure
that that happens in our buildings as
well we need to ensure that our schools
are safe places where our kids can
identify allies that they can talk to if
they're having a tough time have
conversations they may not be able to
have at home have safe spaces where they
can be themselves and know that they're
accepted and truly
belong no no we don't we don't need that